[Musik]
radon ist wir haben eure fragen
gesammelt auf instagram und facebook und
jetzt möchten wir eure fragen
beantwortung in diesem video
ich mach kurze antwort nicht
ausschweifend okay kann ich den anderen
sitzen neben einem männlichen süßen
heiratsantrag macht einen heiratsantrag
ich habe gar keinen gemacht ich habe ich
vor vollendete tatsachen gestellt
demokraten nicht bekannt uns drei wochen
und dann habe ich gesagt dann stellst du
dich deinen eltern bauen und dann habe
ich zeit also wird nicht ab das sind
freunde bringen sie mich definitiv um
kanada gesagt lasst uns heiraten und
dann war das für mich okay
hätten wir gern ich mich immer meine
songs heimlich werden ich habe dann aber
mein aktueller lieblings song willst du
auch dieses lied
in der schule meine lieblingsfächer also
als schülerin auf jeden fall kunst
deutsch habe ich gehasst und mache mal
mein lieblingsfach da glaubst du
eigentlich ist gleich schwer es gab
nicht viel dass wahllos sport jemand
sieht es zwar nicht aber es war mit
nicht sport ich hatte ja ich jedes jahr
eine ehrenurkunde und später als
lehrerin war aber mein lieblingsfach
tatsächlich deutsch und englisch also
das war hat sich da ein bisschen
geändert
ich habe keine eheringe ich habe keinen
an weil ich halt viele in der küche
arbeitet und am anfang hatte ich dann
immer an habe ihn dann in der küche
wieder weg ich weiß gar nicht wo mein
ehering ist ich glaube ich habe den
verloren und irgendwann habe ich gedacht
kommen bevor ich dann eher im verlier
lasse ich ihn einfach die ganze zeit weg
weil ich einfach ja muss ich nicht dran
denken und bei murat ist das problem in
pastell jährigen nicht mehr finde nicht
mehr
ich weiß auch gleich einen finger passen
also hätte man mich vor zehn jahren
gefragt zelle wo siehst du dich mit 30
dann hätte ich gesagt und verheiratet
haben kinder hat ein haus gebaut und
habe einen beruf der mich glücklich
macht und ich glaube ich habe alles
erreicht jetzt muss ich einfach nur
gesund bleiben so alles erreicht ich
wollte ich wohl zwei kinder
jetzt will ich gern 3 das ist ja auch
als lehrerin glücklich geworden jetzt
mach ich halt youtube-videos und noch
ein bisschen was nebenher
ich habe mich an meinen freunden gesagt
ich bin eine frau heiraten
die größe und intelligenter ist als ich
und haben sie über mich gelacht und habe
gesagt wenn die frau intelligent ist
wird sich nicht mit die heiraten soll
das hingekriegt so einfach geht alles
rein
am freitag 10 uhr ein
wasser ist geplant oktober 2006 das ist
vorbei das habe ich auch schon letzten
letzte woche gesagt also diese woche
wird das haus einzugs fertig aber wir
müssen noch putzen auslisten einräumen
ich schätze im laufe der nächsten drei
bis vier wochen aber ich schaffe es
eigentlich diese bereut sich 100 prozent
naja also normalerweise mache ich ja die
rezepte immer zum ersten mal im video
ist wirklich so ich sag's etwas
einfallen probier's direkt im video aus
und dann sagt jan rotter hat noch ein
bisserl zitrone reim machen können am
ende also also ganz ehrlich mit
emotionen
wer meine rezepte nicht hinkriegt dem da
ist willig hopfen und malz verloren
es gab wirklich ein rezept das haben wir
gefilmt und es wurde nie veröffentlicht
und zwar kanäle wurden aber in
frankreich gemacht eine französische
spezialität
ich habe es daheim nicht hingekriegt die
gingen einfach nicht so schön auf keine
ahnung warum
vielleicht mache ist abermals ich werde
nochmal ich werde mich noch mehr
antasten
ich hatte meine nachbarn sehr vermissen
ich glaube sie werden uns nicht
vermissen
dann ziehen sie endlich den lärm los
aber ich werde dich sehr vermissen es
war so schön heimelig dort ist hiernach
unschön und ja die werde ich hoffe wir
müssen ja also ich werde die nacht waren
wirklich vermissen das war am anfang war
es nicht einfach weil da hat es ein paar
nacht waren gegeben
die fanden das halt zu viel im haus los
ist weil die jungs anrufen wunder sind
dann ist ja einfach kurze einfach nicht
ausschweifend okay wir vermissen unsere
nachbarn also ich wirklich ich glaub mir
hatten noch nie eine schlechte
nachbarschaft
star der murat und dann youtube-star der
moral
keine ahnung ich glaube ich weiß dass
ich glaube die meisten nachbarn sind
einfach so weit weg von youtube ich
glaube die teilweise wissen sie gar
nicht was wir machen hat doch ist cool
war mal als ab und zu mache ich mein
posting bei facebook oder so und dann
gehe ich auf die straße und dann rufen
manche aus dem fenster raus he kugel ich
mich sofort gelacht es war so lustig das
ist lustig naja der unterschied ist ja
als auch murat hat kann auch ein drittes
kind ich habe schon drei nasa michaela
morath murat ist das polster kind lässt
sich auch nicht erzählen um ein drittes
kind bologna auf jeden fall also ich
will um mit noch ein drittes kind ich
möchte doch an so und jetzt habe ich
zwei mädchen gehabt klar man hat immer
musst alles mama glaube ich auf kinder
aber momentan erinnert momentan werde
ich mich auf unseren tellern murat noch
gesehen und bin ich nicht mal keinen
sohn bekommen
dann hab ich einen hund habe ich auch
schon gesagt
also macht und nicht wir sehen ja fast
24 stunden zusammen wir arbeiten ja auch
gerade zusammen und dann ist er zu hause
zusammen und ich glaube dafür dass wir
so oft zusammen es im streik wir uns
aber relativ wenig ja ich glaube wir uns
streiten wenn sie mir zuhören würde aber
sie hört mir ehrlich zu und zwar
deswegen weil ich ihr mich zu hören
ich höre einfach weg das ist das einfach
das geht nicht ignorieren manchmal
einfach und dann kommt halt gar nicht
zum streit
murat ach da gab es muss ganz peinliches
okay man hat mir versprochen sie mir ein
eis zu kaufen und hanna den ganzen tag
getrödelt und haben war irgendwann 20
uhr die eisdiele hat schon zu die ensa
und dann hat es der konzern kurz zum
backen
weißt du vater allein hin ich war nicht
mehr ich will nicht zum burger king
gehen ich erste halt auch nichts und
nach malta gekommen kommt man sie mal
hingefahren und hatten damals noch einen
bus mit dem teddy logo drauf da habe ich
bei murat bitte bleibt bestehen und
lauft einfach ein hol das einkommen
wieder zurück ich will dass die leute
mich dabei bei welchen film ja und dann
hatten die sli übertreibt man nett sie
kennen dich doch nicht und fährt halt in
den drive in das ist mir reingefahren
und hatte gestellten 1 und 2 hamburger
spinnstube kann jetzt nicht zwei
hamburger gestellt was mit der zeit
gehen und erst jetzt über 30
dann fahren wir fort zu diesem fenster
wodurch halt das essen herausgegeben
wird
da ist frau rosenkranz
tja wenn er denn da wenn hammer denn da
dies helly unter morath nachrufe
wirklich das fenster rein alle
mitarbeiter nach draußen gucken da
plötzlich acht köpfe beim burger king
raus und gucken hatte moratti berger
bestellt das fand ich ein bisschen
peinlich
aber naja muss ich ja selber stelle
gesagt bestimmt die hochzeit oder also
eigentlich war es ja so dass unser
erstes kind gar nicht geplant war
sondern wir haben gesagt ach mein gott
wenn ich schon dabei wenn ich schwanger
wendet man hat nicht ich glaube da apple
sind anstieg seien deswegen wartet also
wir waren risikobereit und kann kanzler
mir ein kind durch möchte mir noch 2020
wie gesagt wird kindergeld um 20 euro
angehoben und 2020 also beim spielen
kann man zwei rollen murat ist der
drogen der papa also der spielt mit dem
matsch aber ich kämpfe immer mit denen
das wird jetzt blöd an aber wie es gibt
so ein blog das heißt ja was bei uns das
ist so ein wort das wort kennt nur
samira und ich und was heißt kempten und
ich bin eher so für das pädagogische
zuständig die backen zusammen und kochen
malen zeichnen und basteln kneten puzzle
memory so was mache ich dann mit den
kids also ich bewunderte morath dafür
das ist so kreativ ist ob er antworten
auch immer mal wir bekommen echt wenig
kommentare aber wenn man was kriegen
oder was komisches bekommen dann denke
ich so ach ich würde einfach ignorieren
dann antwortet da immer so humorvollen
das problem ist halt nur wenn wir zwei
diskutieren oder reden dann antwortet er
genauso und dann bin ich so kurz vorm
durchdrehen
aber meistens bringt damit schon zum
lachen ich glaube nicht nervt sie nicht
ich glaube mein meister richtig sauer
auf mich und dann sage ich irgendwas und
dann obwohl sie richtig sauer ist fängt
sie an zu lachen hatten die fragen
gestellt ganz ehrlich ob ich noch arbeit
ist jetzt so ernst von morgens bis
abends wenn ich jetzt ganz ehrlich bin
ich wenn ich jetzt jetzt tot umfallen
würde dann hätten sechs arbeitslose
arbeitnehmer ganz ganz sicher als ich
arbeite mit nicht von morgens bis abends
das rezept für eine gute kindererziehung
also ich glaube man sollte immer an
einem strang ziehen sollte man machen
wir aber nicht
da sollten ich dass bruder rezept für
eine gute kindererziehung ist ein ganz
einfach eigentlich alles vorzuleben weil
kinder sind genauso wie du sei laut ist
ich hoffe dass meine kinder alles von
meiner mama haben muss ich wirklich
sagen haben sie auch zum gros größten
teil von der mama und so wie du bist so
sind seine kinder ich glaube ja eine
ganz tolle begabung hat murat erlaubt so
viel und ich sag dann immer nein geht
nicht gestern zum beispiel morgens
einfach einen keks gegessen einfach
morgens um sieben schoko keks und samira
natürlich gleich einmal ich will auch
nicht sagen gäbe es morgen keine kekse
erst nach mittag essen
ich bin da halt schon sonne ist da
sprosses nach dem mittagessen habe ich
im rat angeboten hat hat jetzt nicht
dann erstmalig zum irak sanierer bekannt
jetzt selber entscheiden
möchtest du irgendwann ein dicker bauch
wieder papa ist den keks oder lass mal
gelacht
das ist mein weg kommt übrigens von ella
sie sagt aber papa hat entdeckt bauen
eigentlich gibt es keine menschen die
ich nicht mal ich bin von grund auf
positiv eingestellt keine ahnung
und wenn dann ignoriert sehr einfach ich
lasse nicht so dass jemand mit
schlechter laune macht nicht wie ich zu
menschen stehe ich nicht mag
es musste ich will ganz ehrlich es gibt
sehr wenige menschen ich mag ich also
wenn jetzt mal unser sohn heek kommt
oder irgendwas der antwort habe ich mal
lustig ich glaube das beste ist einfach
nur den menschen menschen den spiegel
vorhält das mache ich gern mit mit
humorvollen antworten die sind dann
nicht irgendwie erniedrigen oder so ist
einfach humorvoll und mit menschen die
ich nicht mag
mit ihm möchte auch nichts machen also
will ich halte mich auch von menschen
fern
die immer negativ sind also wenn jetzt
einmal jemandem freundeskreis ist der
immer alles schlecht macht er immer
alles runter macht mit dieser person
möchte ich auch gar nicht gerne zusammen
sein
manchmal lässt sich nicht vermeiden ich
meine frau nicht jeden tag zu meinem
chef hingegen sagen ich mag dich nicht
dann dann geht es nicht da wohl kann auf
jeden fall mit leuten die ich nicht mag
möchte eigentlich zu tun haben wenn ich
einfach so wenig zeit haben die zeiten
um in einer familie mit freunden
verbringen möchte die was positives
ausstrahlen und ich möchte auch nicht
mit menschen zu tun haben die immer
sagen es geht nicht dass gibt so viele
auf der welt wenn du dinge machst und
immer heißt immer das geht nicht das
geht nicht das geht nicht
aber es gibt so wenig menschen
heutzutage noch die sagen gehabt so
nicht lass uns das noch mal probieren
und das sind das sind für mich die
menschen mit dem ich umgehen möchte ich
mach kurze an gott nicht ausschreiben
okay
okay ich bin ich will dass der borat was
macht dann sage ich immer hart magst du
den müll rausbringen also ich formuliert
halt immer so positiv aber das regt ihn
voll auf war da sagt man ja es gibt
nichts was ich jetzt lieber mögen würde
die macken an das sei wie er hat so die
ist extrem ordentlich die ist die schon
so macht ja die ist wirklich mehr kraft
als morgen kraft heißt weil er muss
immer alles gerade aufgeräumt dort ist
eine tolle eigenschaft und meine meine
schlechten eigenschaften habe ich
schlechte eigenschaften ist wäre es muss
sagen dass ich dort bin ich natürlich
erhalten hat aber was mich an eben mehr
ich kann es nicht hören wenn er trinkt
weil auch schlüpft der macht halten ist
aber darauf achten wer trinkt tee so
nicht so wie normaler mensch so der
macht so
so trinkt und isst dann ungefähr fünf
sechs tassen am tag das ist schon so ein
bisschen america punkt ich bin geduldig
ich vergesse ständig war es kurze
antwort ganz oft vergesse ich was jetzt
habe ich schon zuvor jedoch gegessen was
ich sagen möchte ja viele schlechte
eigenschaften aber ich versuche jeden
tag jedes jahr jeden tag zu verbessern
ist bleibt morath mark an mir dass es
immer positiv bin ich bringe immer gute
laune reiht und ich bin auch sehr
geduldig und an ihm mag ich ganz
besonders das perfekte moore hat also es
sieht manchmal dinge lustig die ich
irgendwie nicht so dass diese dann auch
schon immer den sport brennt und er ist
sehr kreativ
also die kreativität die ich so in der
küche oder im gestalterischen habt hat
er halt bei texten und finde ich schon
graf macht echt gut von anderen
unternehmern
ich meine wir haben mit unserem
unternehmen was es jetzt die worte nicht
angefangen nichts damit man ein
unternehmen wird sondern weil es ein
spaß gemacht haben leidenschaft zum
kochen und backen und das ist eigentlich
bis heute immer noch so es ist halt
gewachsen und wir sind ein komplettes
familien und freunde unternehmen und ich
glaube das ist der kern dabei und wenn
uns was nicht spaß macht und nicht
glücklich macht dann machen wir es
alleine
wir versuchen als nachhaltig zu machen
wir versuchen alles in der region zu
machen das ist nicht immer möglich wir
arbeiten extrem gern mit kamin
unternehmen zusammen wir möchten dinge
produzieren die sinnhaftigkeit haben
alle die was sinnvolles ist ich denke
das ist dass das ist das was das was
meine frau ausmachen sinnvolle sachen zu
machen sport einfach zweimal die woche
[Musik]
die wir uns entspannen ich glaube ich
brauche meine frau entspannt dadurch
dass sie mich einkaufen schickt damit
dass ich mich raus das macht sie ja dich
schickt mich immer wenn zu entspannen
möchte ja und zusammen
aber wir gucken zusammen wenn meine frau
ist im haus ist wenn die kinder aus dem
haus sind und ich ganz allein ich bin
und einfach nur nachrichten schauen da
entspannt ich natürlich entspannt ich
auch mit meiner frau meinen kindern am
morgen aber dann würde ich sagen und
dann kaffee und kaffee auf dem balkon
und dann nachrichten lesen das ist da
entspannt ich und meine frau ist man
immer wenn ich nicht da bin ja wir haben
uns kennengelernt in einer bibliothek
ich glaube sie wollten sie einen sponsor
gesucht für ihre abi party und und sie
hat mich angesehen ich glaube sie hat
sich gleich verteilt ich glaube sie
kennenlernen geschichte ein eigenes
video dazu
das ist ein bisschen etwas längeres ich
kann mit murat nicht romantisch
gemütlich abend ist und daher einfach zu
hektisch weil er sagt halt immer so wie
man ist so arbeitet man auch und wenn
jemand langsam ist noch heiß dann
erarbeitet langweilig sagt aber immer
das essen genießen also ich bin so ein
genussmensch jetzt nicht so mega langsam
aber ich fühle mich halt auch dass er
aus und erzählen gern usw
mit den kindern auf der den tag über
gemacht haben der mond hat ein
geduldeter zog deswegen romantik und
monaten und romantisches essen kerzen
wir haben energiesparlampen ja daheim
ich denke wir leben nicht auf einer burg
ja ich bin leider kein romantiker ich
find's einfach nicht ich weiß es ich
weiß ist es schlimm aber ich bin einfach
ich bin nicht der typ dafür wirklich
nicht
also ich würde gern die personen
kennenlernen die frage gestellt hat also
ich bin nicht mit murat verwahrten sich
was auch vorher nicht wir sind
verheiratet wir kannten uns vorher nicht
aber man sollte auch nicht mit seiner
verwandtschaft heiraten und vielleicht
auch nicht es wird das sollte man auch
ich meine frau verwandt bin total ernst
jetzt kann seit der person stellt die
frage gegenfrage stellen man muss nicht
immer verwandt sein um zu heiraten
also hätte ist nicht meine schwester wo
ich nur sagen so verfährt man muss nicht
mehr verwandt sein und verheiratet ist
ganz ganz wichtig es ist auch meistens
besser nicht verwandt ist und und man
muss auch nicht in die gleiche klasse
gewesen gegangen sein um zu heiraten
wenn ich überlege nämlich eine klasse
warum ich diese person heute geheiratet
hätte was ist das geheimnis
ich glaube man muss immer humorvoll sein
man muss sich aber selber auf die
schippe nehmen können
man muss aber trotzdem immer respektvoll
sein zwei einander klar machen schreitet
wenn man sagt auch vielleicht mal was
nicht so gemeint war aber ich glaube
dass der humor muss mit dabei sein da
ist etwas dabei sein geheimnis ist ich
denke humor ich denke humor und die
gegensätze also sally ist intim viel
hinsicht anders als ich das ist wichtig
und vor allem den anderen zu
unterstützen also es sind viele viele
sachen ein richtiges geheimnis gibt es
da glaube ich nicht aber respekt ist was
ganz tolles liebe natürlich ganz extrem
wichtig
warum nicht mal so viele filme torten
beim morawitz auch das lesen für sich
entdeckt hat
warum mir keine film toten wir machen
weil wir jetzt bücher lesen es hat
einfach nicht gepasst wir machen sie im
nächsten jahr wenn sie jetzt kommt ein
harry potter torte habe ich versprochen
also ich bin 1 75 und murat 168 und wer
was anderes behauptet lügt er wahnsinnig
groß 10 70 er muss nämlich kennengelernt
und ich hab mir bist du eigentlich
erledigt wie groß bist du und dann hat
ich bin 1 65 und 1 70 das stimmt ja auf
41 68
ja ich bin und habe ist schlimm
das hat schlimme jetzt nieder ich werde
in grund und zwar hätte ich gern ich bin
halt immer unsicher beim und was passt
ein hund nimmt man sich hier also ich
liebe zum beispiel so seine sonst so
einen kleinen wie heißen die diese ja
ich habe gerne mops was ich am liebsten
kaffee ganz klar so 100 prozent ich weiß
es nicht ich verstehe es rechnet ganz
ehrlich ich verstehe es nicht warum es
menschen auf dieser welt gibt die sub
nicht mögen ich verstehe ihr müsst immer
die in der gelben verpackung nehmen
einfach die in der gelben verpackung
ich darf mir keine produktplatzierung
machen ich darf nicht sagen dass sie von
act ist aber holt die aus der gelben
verpackung die ist echt genial
ich warte auch immer dass sie mich
anrufen werbe fragen wir machen möchten
ist wir rufen aber nicht an noch nicht
morgen vielleicht schon
weil es einfacher ist positiv zu denken
als negativ wenn man schon morgens gute
laune hat und andere damit am steckt es
kommt ja auch wieder auf einen zurück
das ist irgendwie einfacher und schöner
als schlechte laune zu verbreiten
wenn ich so süß und chris rahmen der
dann durchs leben geht und wo hier
gemeckert und gemeckert und das finde
ich schön
das wären aber positiv sein sie lacht
halt immer aber ich weiß dass ich also
sie ist nicht immer pussi wellen immer
positiv eingestellt heißt ja auch immer
heißer irgendwie auch immer ein bisschen
naiv zu sein wobei ein bisschen naiv zu
sein auf der welt schadet nicht also ich
finde naivität finde ich gar nicht durch
das meistens die glücklichen menschen ja
aber sie hat einfach immer gut die laune
ich weiß auch nicht aber ein clown
verschluckt aber die da geht's halt gibt
ganz ganz wenige situationen leben wo
sie nicht positiv ist eigentlich jetzt
erzählen am 19 10 2008 und 2007 19
dezember 2007 an dem tag haben wir unser
erstes date oder sommer zusammen gehören
meiner sturm glück gehabt wirklich
wahnsinn wirklich du hast glück gehabt
so eine glückliche frau ehrlich du bist
der beste was verbrachte man im kino ja
und zwar in einen thriller in einem
proben und dann hat er sogar 19 03 ja
irgendwie so mit nicolas cage oder mit
wem wann der john hughes echt ja und hat
einfach so gemacht ja cool
ein tipp von mir ist es ein fehler mit
einer frau ins kino zu gehen beim
liebesblind ersten horrorfilm reingeht
dann kommt sie näher
definitiv ja na ja bei ihm also ganz
ehrlich wenn die mal nicht in der hand
ab ist mir egal ich meine freunde rufen
mich andere befreundet und steht es um
leben tod hast du mir auf dem bau
gearbeitet
ich liebe meine zuschauer und meine
kommentare ich lese gerne und
beantwortet gerne aber ich leg aufs
handy einfach gern mal weg wenn ich auf
dem spielplatz mit kindern oder mit den
kindern spielt und koche und backe dann
handy.de 123 vorbild das ist ein erfolg
könntest du dir vorstellen lage zum sex
im bademantel brötchen zu kaufen wir
machen wieso morstadt wer macht es
ich mache ich würde es machen elvis oder
bademantel machen polizisten exorzisten
ex-polizisten solche leute ich weiß
nicht was die leute ja du bist auch ich
mal lieber mit bademantel nationen
nicht gucken ich räumung vorlauf ich
habe meine sachen selber auf ich stehe
auf der in der küche und wenn es deine
mama sie wurde prozent was macht man
schon in der küche
wir haben muss sofort machen das was dem
gedanken kommt es stimmt meistens gott
sei also das muss aber unterscheiden
ich erzähle die kinder pädagogisch und
du erzählst du halt dann zu autoritär
nach dem leben so wie es leben halt ich
kann schon ein kind nicht schimpfen nur
weil sie ein glas umgestoßen hat mein
gott das ist ein kind wird dann bleibt
immer gleich aus logisch aber zeigen
dass es nicht geht ja ja aber nicht bei
so banale sachen ich glaube wenn wir nur
nachteile erziehung gegen das kind
irgendwann mal gerne ihre kunst
studieren
das ist ein germanistik und konstant
schnitt fast schon mal im flugzeug
geworden gehört boah da ist jemand um
geflogen kann weil jemand eine
kunststudentin ja schon mal was gehört
nein mit meistens ein arzt gerufen
extravagant werke keiner von uns ist
romantisch doch sie sogar
also warum man die shopping mit herz und
herz über all das konnte ich gar nicht
hier
ich bin fünf bisher
ich bin jetzt 19 jahre zehn jahre zu
leben zehn jahre ziehen
ich bin mir ganz sicher dass ich mich in
diesen zehn jahren zwei stunden zwei
jahre auch nicht nur gemacht haben nein
weil ich habe eh schon
ich war ja ich war ja bleibt die steirer
27 626 du kannst nicht mehr gefahren ich
habe 26 jahre lang auf dich gewartet
26 ja gleich 26 jahre auf sie gewartet
habe habe ich insgesamt den letzten zehn
jahren auch noch mal zwei jahre auf sie
gewartet sondern immer wenig sagt jetzt
bist du los wir haben jetzt ein termin
war mal achtung achtung seit du jetzt
mal ganz ehrlich gemeint ist halt so nah
der moral macht einfach sich selber
fertig sich selber fertig das geht halt
in 30 minuten
ich mache mich fertig ich mich was ich
mache ich putze davor
weißt du machst nur dich fertig das geht
in zehn minuten du stehst auf wunsch die
zähne er durst und dann bist du schon
fertig und ich muss halt mich richten
dann noch die kinder fertig machen die
brotdosen machen dann räume ich noch auf
putzt das bad und das alles morgens
alles innerhalb von einer stunde null
prozent 100 prozent glaubt sei es ihr
nicht zu was wir können einfach eine
kamera installiert gucken wetter morgen
legt das thema mittel und dann und das
sieht das nicht ein weg ist doch nicht
normal
wir sagen du warst aber das war nur als
ich 18 war da hatte ich den führerschein
ganz frisch und am nächsten tag da bin
ich gegen so einen brandneuen mini
cooper gefahren
ja ich hab's nicht mal gemerkt mein
bruder hat es gemerkt aber ich hab keine
fahrerflucht begangen ich habe den
fahrer gesucht und dann habe ich
insgesamt noch mal glaube ich fünf mal
ein auto gerammt einmal war es eine
garage einmal rechts vor links war alles
mit papas alten ford fiesta und dann
habe ich irgendwann murat kennengelernt
und dann aber seitdem eigentlich nicht
mehr als 900 besser und ordentlich dass
so ein putz tochter aber das ist nicht
die quantität sondern die qualität
ich bin sauber rein und ordentlich und
macht halt öfter weil ich muss ja schon
mal ein staubsauger zeige erwischt und
so gleichzeitig meine produktplatzierung
nein das nicht aber es ist der hammer
ist ein hammer die die leute wie mich
auf ihn zu erfolgen müssen
ok nächste frage
streich für sich nicht
also ich nicht ja weiterhin das heißt ja
ja ich habe warum es einmal vorsichtig
ja ich weiß ich weiß das ist für mich so
ein thema wo ich gar nicht gar nichts
mit anfangen kann sowie steigender
existiert also eigentlich ja was machen
eigentlich auch zusammengehen
ich würde sagen ich aber wir stehen in
kontakt kommt aus lima erkennt
verschiedene fachgebiete ja so
beschäftigt war schwer bewacht so lagen
90 prozent der fach- und alles vorüber
fachgebiet schreiben alles was kochen
ist ist sie okay das thema wechseln noch
mal was war die letzte frage jetzt nicht
irgendwas sinnvolles sowie warum steht
hier im handel bauen ja zum weiterbau
spielt dann warum sowas irgend was cool
ist vielleicht kein junger mensch aber
ich stehe hier könnten so so
frage-antwort-spiel der öfter machen ja
alles was ich so aktuell bewegt könnte
uns gerne einfach fragen genau und wir
beantworten euch dann herunter erklärt
und es können rating so hochzeit und
kennenlernen und so ein thema für sich
also wenn ihr wollt machen wir da ein
ganz eigenes video daraus ja ich habe
sogar unsere hochzeit cd wiedergefunden
es ist nicht das erste modell ich hab
dich glaubst du vergraben das schlimmste
was ist für mich überhaupt gibt es diese
hochzeit szili baum anzuschauen
also falls sie interesse an weiteren
frage und antwort videos dann schreibt
gerne in die kommentare
und dass forschung und gesagt morgen in
frankfurt
aber das wort nicht ansonsten produkt
platzieren
jawohl es diesen einfach in frankfurt
morgen sorgt hier steht ja das interesse
dann blind einfach ein
produktplatzierung und dann ist es okay
den starken markennamen darum wäre ja
und es gibt bully weg ist kostenlos
es gibt da ein eintritt und am sonntag
um 16 uhr bei vox ja und es seine
premiere
es stimmt dass morgens gut premiere ist
ganz neues buch poster und zwar ein food
fotografie buch hat nichts mit meinem
vermuten dass bei murat gibt es dann ein
buch oder füße und bei mir ein buch über
essen und am sonntag um 16 uhr bei vox
da erwartet euch das apfel streut stellt
eine dame und das haben sie nicht gut da
war um mit unserem nachbarn andreas auf
der streuobstwiese richtig richtig cool
also eine richtig tolle sendung mit
tollen rezepten schaltet gerne 17 sicher
nicht gemacht
ich muss jetzt schon immer noch größer
ja hallo mama
einfach sein herbstzeit ist apfel zeit
ich möchte ein drei-gänge-menü zaubern
und in jedem gang tochter apfel auf in
der vorspeise in der hauptspeise in der
nachspeise und es soll alles so
unterschiedlich schmecken so dass
wirklich keine langeweile aufgaben fünf
hafenstadt nähe über herzhaften
blätterteig bis hin zu süßen tarte das
apfel mini und fertig einfach sally
sonntag 16 uhr bei vox